hey guys and welcome to another episode
of my 1hour flipping challenge uh today
we're going to be revisiting a topic
that we did before and that is flipping
the top 100 items um the top 100 most
traded items I should say uh and it's
really popular and people really enjoyed
the last one so I thought I'd do another
one um again we're just going to be
taking the top 100 items right off the
RuneScape website and we're just going
to be restricted to flipping those uh
lots of options uh it's going to be a
lot of quick flips uh not huge margins
but it's going to be interesting and a
lot more entertaining to watch uh flips
just fly by and we're going to be
starting with 30 mil today all right
hope you guys enjoy and let's get
started okay guys so we have uh 30 mil
in our inventory and uh yeah let's get
started uh so I didn't come into this
with much of a plan I do have the top
100 items open here and once again this
is going to be uh for the last month uh
so the items should be roughly the same
but what try to do some different ones
uh but again moving down from the top uh
we will do Z scales and cannonballs um
we do have a little bit more money than
we had last time so we'll be able to
kind of have a couple more active flips
at once and now zel scales are much
cheaper than they were last time uh
121 into 18 that's pretty good actually
for Z scales definitely going to do that
and the limit on Z scales is 30k that's
that's pretty good flip to start with
and we'll just um take a few off the end
again just so that we don't actually hit
the buying limit so we can go recheck
the item after which is always useful so
we are going to be using a GE tracker
for the buying limits cuz I don't know
them all off by heart of course uh so
there we go cannonballs is going to be a
7K limit uh pretty good margin on there
uh so we'll do
6900 at 197 and we're looking to get a
five GP margin on cannonballs so not too
bad okay the Adam and dart has a 4 GP
margin which is pretty good and they do
trade a lot now uh the limit is is I
can't remember now looks like
11,000 uh so we'll go ahead and do some
Adam and darts
156 and we'll just do 110k I guess okay
dragon bones do have a one I guess 25 GP
margin on them uh which isn't too bad
we'll just we'll do 5K uh they're a lot
more expensive but they do come through
very quickly if we go have a quick look
at dragon bones on G tracker looks like
the limit is
7500 and uh unfortunately GT tracker is
a little bit down right now now uh but
we can still see the limits luckily and
uh the bones are coming through pretty
quickly okay the mythro bar has a uh 20
GP margin on it uh so we'll go ahead and
do 4K myth Ballers for now uh we may
have to bump up these other offers cuz
they are not coming through uh adamant
darts and cannonballs well we'll leave
them in a little bit longer okay Z
skills went up to 119 but that's totally
fine I didn't you don't usually get a uh
3gp margin on Z scales not very likely
it's not impossible but okay we'll reut
that offer in and we have the adment
bars adment darts and dragon bones are
almost all the way through and look at
that Z skills are instantly bought
23,000 of them right away pretty well uh
so that's good and let's just make sure
we get all our offer slots filled before
we start selling them off okay the law
Rune has a 7 GP margin on it which is
extremely good um and all these skills
have come through at 119
each and we're going to sell those off
for 121 which will be a 60k profit not
bad okay nature runes have a 2 GP margin
on it which is pretty much all you can
ever hope to get on natur runes but they
are extremely quick and we'll do 10,000
of those now uh we do have a couple
offers that are nearly completed uh
dragon bones I think may have stopped
coming through we'll just recheck the
margin here 2920 we'll just sell those
off for 2920 right now and uh just let
it settle down for a bit sometimes s you
just have to leave items for a bit uh so
10 839 is what we're selling them for
and we bought for
10773 so a 607k margin on those so not
too bad and raw sharks actually have a
really good margin on them as well uh
765 into 778 or something like that uh
now I'm not sure what the margin or the
bind Lim is on sharks we have enough for
10,000 anyway uh let's just have a quick
look raw sharks uh 15,000 interesting
well we cannot do that many not even
close so we'll just do 6K for
now and yeah looks good okay all the
adamant darts have come through for
157 and adamant darts I think it's an
11k limit so we should be able to check
it one more
time
163 that's pretty
good so off for 163 uh so 1630 is what
we're selling it for we bought it for
$570 that is a 60k profit off darts as
well uh the myal bars have all come
through and I think we may go buy ahead
or go ahead and buy some more of these
uh we just didn't have enough at the
time 879 is what we can sell it
for that's really good so
3516 is what we're selling it for and we
bought it for 344 so that is 112k profit
roughly and we did sell off all the
dragon bones now I'm not sure if I
should buy more of these mythal bars or
more dragon bones we're going to have to
see uh but these cannonballs aren't
actually buying so we'll just pull that
out now to get give us a little more
space and I think we're going to buy
more mythal bars because that is a very
good
margin
879 and uh let's just see if they sell
for the same price uh yeah looks good
and what was the limit on myal bars
again 10,000 uh so we could go ahead and
do 6K of these minus a little bit and
we're going to put another flip in for
dragon bones quickly it sells about a 15
GP margin on it uh which isn't too bad
okay all of the Adam and darts have sold
uh pretty much all one go uh so for 163
and yeah I think that was a 60k profit
there so pretty good and we've also
bought all the nature runes for 228 now
hopefully we can still get a 2gp margin
on nature runes which isn't amazing but
that's still an easy 20K uh 230 yep
still 2 GP and mythal darts actually
managed to get a uh three or four GP
margin on these and they're extremely
cheap cheap uh so we'll go ahead and do
that that's a 30 or 40K profit right
there and we still have 1.4 mil left but
I think we'll just leave it for now okay
all our raw sharks came through just a
second later for 766
each and this item I believe did
actually have a pretty nice margin for
the price so 4668 is what we're selling
them for and we bought them for
4596 uh so just a 60k margin but that's
pretty good for raw sharks Okay so we've
sold off all of the raw sharks and uh I
think we'll definitely go ahead and buy
another bit of those uh the limit I
think was 10 no it was 15,000 I remember
that was a very extremely high amount
for what I thought it was so I think
we'll go ahead and buy another 10,000
and if we can uh 765 and a
779 uh that's still a very good margin
going to go by 10,000 of these minus a
bit we don't actually have enough for
that ah we'll just do another 9,000
that's fine and we'll pretty much have
hit the limit then
and then we have a dragon bones coming
through and I guess we've done 7,500 of
these so far so I think we have another
2500 we could do if we wanted to
2919 probably only going to get 20 or
30k off of this 7,300 is what we're
selling it for and we bought it
for actually yeah yeah actually never
mind that's only about a 30k profit uh
so not terrible okay all of the mythal
bars have sold off which is extremely
exciting uh 878 is what we sold them for
so 3512 and we bought them for I don't
know I think it was over oh down here
52k profit off that that is extremely
good and we have another 6K mythro bars
almost all the way through and look at
this isn't just this just satisfying
everything's coming through reasonably
quickly you can see I can sit here and
just watch it I don't have to go
anywhere I don't have to wait I'm
literally just watching all these offers
coming through at once and it's
beautiful okay you logs actually have a
7 GP margin than them as well uh now I
don't know the we'll have to quickly
check the limit for you logs luckily
most of these high volume items the
limit has been published uh 12K on you
logs and yeah probably just do um not
quite we'll do 10K we'll do for now uh
mythal bars have come through and we are
looking to sell them off again for 878
is a wonderful
margin
878 so 50
264 and we bought them for 5102 so
that's 160k profit off mythra bars
that's great okay all the raw sharks
have come through I think we may have
hit the limit on this one or we're just
kind of unlucky but either way we'll
just pull it up we only missing like
three let's just check if we can recheck
the margin
here no so we did hit the limit uh so
we'll just have to assume that our last
offer is correct and that was for 77
eight is what we're selling them for so
uh we're selling them for pretty well uh
mil and we bought them for 6890 so
that's 110k profit off of raw sharks
that's really nice oh look instantly
sold pretty well so that's awesome pull
that out okay law runes are all through
for 191 uh now it's been a while since
we checked the margin let's see if oh
[__] oh no we're good uh 197 that is
really good 97 we sell them for 1970 and
we bought them for 1910 so a 60k profit
easily on runes which is awesome okay
Oak planks have a 7 GP margin on them as
well uh we'll just do another 10k of
these I don't H we'll see what the limit
is
quickly Oak
planks I think they're 11k 13k uh so
yeah we'll do 13k then why
not okay we we need to readjust a couple
things here dragon bones have not come
through in a while uh we do have another
2500 of those we could flip we wanted to
dragon
bones they Dro down a
bit oh okay no only buy 1 GP that's fine
uh so
298 and you loged her through for
362 and we're selling them for 368 that
is a 6 GP pretty good and a free to-play
item to boot as well and dragon bones
are pretty well instantly sold off there
we go another good item is the Ruby bolt
e uh very good margin there uh yeah
we'll do
11,500 of these why
not for about 4 mil looks good okay I
think we're going to pull the mythal
darts uh for one it kind of looks like
we had to bind them even though I'm not
sure if we did but either way uh they're
coming through reasonably slowly so
we'll go ahead try to sell them off now
did we actually have to buy limit here
okay we did all right uh I'd say let's
sell these for 60 all right so we're
just rechecking the Metro Bar because
none have come through and we noticed uh
that it has crashed quite a bit I don't
really know why this could have happened
but we'll just tried for one to start
just by selling them for what we bought
them for uh so for a net loss of zero
would be nice but we're not sure if
we're going to get that or not okay so
to help make more room I went and
recheck theol scale margin and it had
dropped uh to well what we bought it for
so we probably made 50 on 50% of the
scales we made a 2 GP margin and on the
rest we broke even uh so not too bad I
guess probably 20 or 30k on that okay so
we bought all the oak planks pretty well
anyway uh 1282 of them uh for 492 each
now what can we sell them for 497 so a 5
GP margin on that uh will be about 60k
so 63 63 and we bought them for 62 98 so
yeah about 65k margin so not too bad
okay there we go the mythal bars have
started to come through which is awesome
I know we're just going to break even on
these um but
unfortunately um we're not going to
profit but we didn't lose any money cuz
we could have lost 120k off that so
that's kind of nice to see all right I'm
just getting rid of these nature runes
cuz they're taking up space and I don't
know why they're taking so long to sell
the last little bit but that's okay H
it's a 10 GP margin it's not
great but that's still going to be 40K
and we'll leave that until we find
another item that might work better uh
now we did want to do battle stabs and
they are really
expensive uh for how quickly they sell
anyway so where did it go battle staffs
are like eight or 9k each so 89 38 but
they trade a lot so the total
8854 but that's really good okay never
mind abandon this we need to get as much
money in here as possible uh mythal bars
have yet to come through uh law runes
and these are selling off that's the
money that we need there unfortunately
that's okay uh so battle stabs
8854 and we can afford 2,000 right now
and just look how quickly those are
coming through and we got 520 in like 3
seconds 580 it's a very quick item and
this margin's really nice that is a
a 60 or 70k margin or not K margin but
60 or 70k we're going to get on that and
we're going to start just selling them
off right away uh for
8937 cuz this margin changes a lot so
you really want to be on top of
it so off of these 2,000 we're going to
get 168k we're going to make off of
these 2,000 battle stabs assuming we can
sell these quickly enough all right so
we have all the battle stabs coming
through already we just got to sell them
off for 8937 okay and just like that we
have sold
1,42 of them and uh we're going to take
out all the money we can from anything
that is sold whatsoever and we're going
to put more money into the battle staff
all right buy 2,000
more do we have enough oh we did
actually have enough for 2,000 more and
8935 is what they're selling for now
okay they pretty much all come through
for uh
565k that we'll be able to put in our
inventory for each th000 we're flipping
here we're getting 100K so that is
insane law runes selling for 197 I'll
deal with that in a second because the
battle stabs are already coming through
we got to keep on top of this and we're
going to sell these for 8934 that's
another 100K if we flip all these and
we're dropping it down to
8860 I think that actually has been yeah
yeah it's a little bit higher up now of
course the margin is going to be
slimming down but I mean there's only a
certain amount of time you can take
advantage of an opportunity like this so
another 1300 battle stabs we're going to
try to buy and we've already sold off
the rest um so actually we'll just go
ahead and rechange this quickly 2500
battle stabs let's go oak logs or Oak
planks have all sold off I think we
still made a little bit of money off
that okay we sold off all the battle
stabs for 8934 uh that's mean 50k worth
of sold battle stabs there 8934 oh boy
all right that may have been the end of
the Gold Rush there okay we actually
instantly sold those battle stabs for
8934 uh so I don't think that's going to
be uh we'll pull most of this money out
okay I forgot we have actually cooked
shark I forgot about that entirely I
think the limit may be 10K on this
one uh but that'll be a hopefully a
quick flip because we only have 13
minutes left uh so not a lot of time for
this uh but luckily most of our
important things have sold off uh so we
haven't really and we haven't I don't
think we've lost any money on a single
flip so that's pretty exciting okay
that's why I'd like to see that raw
sharks are already through I only took
like 30 seconds and we're going to sell
those off for 950 so it'll be an easy
50k uh 950 hopefully those can sell off
quickly and we just check the margin on
dragon bones H why not we have like
another 20500 we can do roughly let's do
2400 and I mean that'll be another 50
60k I mean it all adds up pretty quick
and law runes have totally
sold couldn't tell you how much we made
on those there's a bit of a cluster [__]
unfortunately okay death runes have a 4
GP margin but we don't have a lot of
time so I mean [__] uh we'll do
10,000 hopefully we can actually buy
these in time I mean they're of course a
heavily traded item but 10 minutes is
only 10 minutes unfortunately okay so we
only have 2 minutes left but luckily we
have sold off all the planks which I
wasn't sure if they are going to come
through or not and the dragon bones H
surprisingly the Sharks and death runes
are the last to sell okay guys so we're
finishing up uh the 1 hour of flipping
the top 100 items uh death runes have
come through uh sharks still haven't I
don't know I guess they're dropping down
so we'll probably just instantly sell
those for a moderate loss but it's not a
huge deal uh we bought them for 944 so
we'll lose about 50 or 60k on this last
item uh but I'm still pretty happy with
how the hour went if only we had been
able to hold on to the battle staff
margin for a bit longer uh but that's
okay 2 1
z uh so we're going to insta sell the
sharks uh
for 943 okay that's not a huge deal uh
so let's see how much we made off of 1
hour of flipping the top 100 items uh
keep in mind we didn't get any home runs
I mean the battle STS were good but uh
we mostly just consistent profits coming
through 30 40K in each flip and yeah
let's see how much we made looks like
976k so we're just shy of a mill
although probably put a mill on the
title but uh uh yeah so really you can
see how profitable high volume items can
be I know I had 30 mil to start with and
that is quite a lot for some of you but
a lot of these flips are doable even on
lesser amounts of money and it just goes
to show uh you can make quite a bit of
an hour of flipping these items plus it
is really satisfying because you get to
see the items coming in you can actively
be doing something um and yeah so I hope
you guys enjoyed uh the second attempt
at this and I will see you guys in the
next video
n
[Music]